[موسيقى]
الانتخابات التركيه بايجاز من اسطنبول
مرحبا بكم للمره الاولى بتاريخ تركيا
المجلس الاعلى للانتخابات يعلن اجراء جوله
ثانيه من الانتخابات الرئاسيه في 28 من
مايو بحسب نتائج غير النهائيه حيث حصل
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان على
49.5% من الاصوات بينما حصل منافسه كمال
كلشتار اوغلو مرشح تحالف الشعب المعارض
على
44.8 بالمئه في مشاركه هي الاكبر بتاريخها
المجلس الاعلى للانتخابات يعلن وصول نسبه
المشاركه في التصويت الى
88.90% داخل تركيا واثنين وخمسين فاصله
سته بالمئه خارج البلاد وسط استقطاب حاد
وانقسام بين الناخبين شهدته الانتخابات
الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه المرشح الرئاسي عن
تحالف اجداد سنان اوغان يحصد اصوات اكثر
من مليونين و700 الف ناخد بنسبه
اثنين بالمئه وصرح اوجان ان شرط دعمه لاحد
المرشحين سواء اردوغان او كريشتار اوغلو
في جوله الاعاده والتخلي عن الاحزاب
الكرديه واعاده اللاجئين تحالف الجمهور
بقياده الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان يحقق فوزا
لافتا في الانتخابات البرلمانيه بنسبه
49.5% يضمن من خلالها الاكثريه البرلمانيه
وحزب الرفاه من جديد الاسلامي احد احزاب
تحالف الجمهور يحصد اكثر من مليون و500
الف صوت ويحجز خمسه مقاعد في البرلمان
وذلك لاول مره منذ تاسيسه عام 2018 على يد
فاتح اربكان نجلس سياسي الراحل نجم الدين
اربكان الى اللقاء